au bonjour à tous
n'avez vous jamais été invité un peu 06
10 7-6 11/9 people aux années c'est pas
les magouilles je t'avais pas coupé on
ne peut pas dire ma couille sur les
chaînes basique du câble vous êtes
pareils à la maison oh non on s'entend
pas aussi bien à la maison lui même
j'adore tous vos livres émaux trier
pouvons-nous faire une trêve
oui enfin enfin quand as tu déjà demandé
une trêve
tu réalises que tu commences une dispute
à propos d'une traîne cher héros smith
voici ton petit fils petit-fils cette
incroyable je me suis même pas fait
retoucher
ils sont grands mais il est où le mot il
est en prison et le gamin va vivre ici
aux viticulteurs
on peut pas garder un enfant on n'a même
pas su gérer cette saloperie de
yorkshire terrier que je vis avec paul
erasmus
ils sont gays il ya certains mots que
vous ne devez jamais utilisé quand vous
parler à une personne qui est gay ne
jamais dire ta gueule ne jamais dire
suceurs de willis et white des services
de protection de l'enfance
pourriez-vous venir tous les deux s'il
vous plaît seixois aux fantômes as il a
traversé une période assez intense
j'étais fan de sabre laser à poil en
montagne d'autant plus ici que le
matériau source est également gay
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as de faire c'est un peu
ça je serais sorti avant son bilan
l'église mais l'arizona et si moi je
leur ai dit écoute bien tu partiras
nulle part c'est promis
si tu promets de pas vendre cette drogue
on donnera 100 $ par semaine
tu as le plus gros coeur de tous les
hommes que je connaisse
[Musique]
on va tout bazarder de manière ils sont
sur le net ou est ce que j'ai dit ça
[Musique]